en fait moi avant j'étais professeur
d'histoire de l'art
en CAP soudeur bétonner option foot
il y a beaucoup d'élèves difficiles et
il y en a beaucoup qui sont en échec
alors franchement c'est pas du tout
parce qu'il s'en fout tout parti
travaille pas donc faut arrêter de dire
ça non c'est juste parce qu'ils sont
excessivement con
heureusement les parents sont là pour
les encourager
qu'il faut s'accrocher qui vont réussir
et ils le disent avec une grande
sincérité parce que très souvent les
parents aussi sont excessivement cons
non mais ça va les élèves franchement ça
va ils sont gentils
parfois il me laisse des petits mots sur
les tableaux
[__]
grosse [__] sale [__] non c'est gentil
ça veut dire qu'il me considère un peu
comme quelqu'un de leur famille
par contre un jour le petit Saïd et son
frère ont écrit
va te faire [__] [__] voilà bon là
j'ai quand même appelé le directeur
parce que enfin quand des élèves
arrivent comme ça à faire des phrases
entières
[Musique]
il doit pas absolument quitter l'option
foot
j'ai décidé de les réorienter en oeuf
sur journaliste
un jour alors que tout le monde me
disait tu verras il arrive avec et ben
un jour le petit saillie de son frère
ont réussi à intégrer un grand journal
français et ça ça va encourager je me
suis dit
si c'est deux frères kwashi on peut
réussir
ça a réalisé leurs rêves et enfin tout
le monde peut y arriver alors ça va
donner de l'espoir et avec mes élèves
j'ai décidé de tout reprendre à zéro ça
a commencé par le respect c'est vrai
qu'ils avaient quand même un peu des
petites lacunes là-dedans donc voilà je
leur ai appris que le respect bah c'est
par exemple que les professeurs
acceptent que Mélanie et Fatima portent
la burqa peu dans les cours donc ils
m'ont répondu
oui qu'elle ne portait pas la burqa mais
qu'elles étaient en option à pic culture
je leur ai également appris que quand un
professeur leur demande en début de
cours sortez votre matériel
il signifie en aucun cas qu'il aimerait
poursuivre le courage de nous devant une
farandole de [__] de toutes les couleurs